hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to toribash the game where
you're a physical rag doll and that guy
is freaking breakdancing over there I
promise you I am NOT gonna be that good
at this game but it's a game where you
take turns on flexing and contracting
different body parts to make yourself do
whatever the hell just tap behind that
screen over there so let me walk you
through this because it's quite
complicated in the beginning and I
actually had to take a long time to
learn the tutorial so that I wouldn't
suck so much ass anyway as you can see
my name is Marky buck and I'm playing
against a computer on player over here
so what you need to do is you need to
adjust your body parts so that they do
certain actions and instead of being
stupid hopefully they're gonna be not be
bad so as you can see I'm going for the
flying kung-fu technique okay that's all
I get that's literally all you get for
the first move but this opponent here
isn't actually gonna do anything so I'm
gonna try so let's go a little bit
further I thing to be doing something
horribly wrong nope nope nope
contracting abs moving jostling moving
around I'm gonna get up eventually I
seem to have grabbed my own ankle and
I'm gonna extend my knee and piss slap
him in the face and say oh wait no no
wait I got a hand wait a minute I'm
gonna give it to you okay as you can see
is very much intimidated by me and my
moves arms and now when I extend my
knees his arms up I think is officially
done
I just gotta train him of all ifs blood
and all of his internal organs are gonna
turn to mush and then I'm gonna be able
to move on gotcha [ __ ] now you're done
son you're done now if I just like just
figure out what the hell else I'm gonna
do about this I'll get you grew up right
across the chest grab on I missed
I'm gonna grab on to me and then I'm
gonna go over here
they give me I need to talk with you for
a second
curl up into this ball well that looked
impressive right off the bat but then it
turned into something a little bit silly
now here's on the Sun you're done you're
dead I'm gonna guess then I just stare
to extend my elbow and raise my right
shoulder done that didn't do much but I
bet it was very painful for you maybe we
stop being such a douche oh to be able
to do something over here instead of
just being a rag doll piece of [ __ ]
we're gonna try something a bit
different here whoa um okay oh I see how
this is gonna be well I'm just gonna
have to get you harness
where did I go what's happening Oh God
your top hat is spinning out of control
here okay that was normal it's all about
flexing the butt cheeks in this yeah oh
I missed well maybe that was intentional
because look how awesome I look try this
on for size big boy dancing
ripped off my own arm hey I'm just gonna
breakdance for a little bit how about
yourself
Oh God oh oh hello boom
I don't know about you guys but I can
watch this for quite a while pop okay
here we go come before you something's
happening how come are you oh that
didn't work out in my favor oh I do my
dad's back here
you like my botox guys this check out
how many mods there are for this game
there are literally hundreds and
hundreds of mods that people have been
making to make this game a bit more
interesting so let's try something here
ski jump
why not baby go oh boy oh that guy did a
backflip all I'm gonna do is flip into
death thank you thank you very much ski
jump is spectacularly horrible oh I'm
over there very dead thank you um well
alright then why do I still lose this
time I'm not gonna lose is he got
special emotions in here you think you
going to beat me or I'm just gonna hit
you very hard and then go perfect thrust
oh no your head is off oh you have got
to be kidding me
how am I supposed to do this this is
flippin impossible alright here we go
[Music]
am i doing gymnastics yet beautiful yeah
yeah you stay down I play with my big
long chopsticks over here oh well then
bring it on it was just setup for me to
lose how is that supposed to be any fun
[Music]
whoa the one thing that I learned about
this game is number one it's trying to
kill me
and number two I'm very bad at it and
such Oh
go baby go dancing came off and I'm
probably gonna die I like I'm flailing
into death when the other guys is like
oh this [ __ ] he keeps dying I want
you to go die in a fire and never see me
ever again
[Music]
alright so that was Tori best that was
really a lot of fun it takes a lot to
set up but it's still a really cool game
it's got multiplayer a lot of mods you
can customize your own stuff it's free
to play for now but there's just a few
things you can buy for customization
goes I think but it's a great game I
give it a try just released on Steam
recently so either way thank you all so
much for watching leave a like if you
enjoyed this video and as though
I will say you in the next video
seeing things out of the corner of my
eyes in my own apartment so I just want
to play a nice relaxing game where I can
show you guys some real commentary into
gaming the insights behind the indie
game world so let's get started okay so
obvious what the hell